uh well as you can see and i'm pleased
to say we're joined now by the working
pension secretary's coffee lovely to see
you this morning and
and i understand that rwanda is away
from your beef which we will be spending
a few minutes on but we must start with
rwanda i mean
who could have guessed that the first
flight to romana would would not have
taken off but frankly pretty much
everyone bar the government so what
happens now
well the government has expected a lot
of legal challenges and we went through
the british courts who gave the go-ahead
for this flight to happen uh despite the
challenges that happened so i think you
know frankly the government is
disappointed in decision i've never
known such a quick decision made by
somebody the echr on this uh on on
trying to intervene and i think the
public will be surprised we have
european judges overruling um british
judges but nevertheless uh i know the
home office is already getting ready for
the next flight and uh you know we will
continue to
prepare and uh try and overturn any
future legal challenges as well do you
think that the amount of money that we
will have spent on on this flight of
flight which didn't take off which will
undoubtedly run into the six figures it
must run into the six figures do you
still maintain that this was money well
spent
well i know that we spend millions of
pounds a day on a broken asylum system
uh what i do know is that the priority
for the government is to make sure that
safe legal routes are prioritized and
that we try and do whatever we can
through deterring illegal unsafe routes
because the only people that profit are
the smugglers who frankly push people
out into boats and don't care if they
arrive or not so when will we get this
next flight when when are we
anticipating seeing perhaps a repeat of
the scenes we saw yesterday well it's
for the home office to focus on their
operational matters i'm not sure it's
something i particularly want to
broadcast uh but nevertheless
preparations are underway and i'm
confident that the home secretary pretty
will be working with her team uh to take
the next steps that are appropriate days
are weeks i mean you can give us a rough
ballpark surely i'm not going to get
into operational uh disclosures just in
terms of of the the embarrassment and it
clearly is an embarrassment for the
government we began the week with 130
packs supposed to be on this flight we
went down to seven and now no one has
been able to leave again i reiterate
this point given that everyone apart
from the government could see this
coming
do you still maintain that this was
value for money i do maintain its value
for money and anything we can do to
deter people uh bingo put in the hands
of people smugglers is efforts that are
well deserved in terms of making sure
that we try and stop that and get people
towards safe legal routes this is an
unsafe thing to be doing to pushing
people out into the channel
we know that's the case we know that's a
case of traffickers actually in all
parts of the world but nevertheless uh
this got through british courts uh
through the legal challenges and let's
say we're surprised and disappointed
that the european judges have overturned
that i mean it is that you mentioned
deterrence i mean is there any evidence
that this has yet had any kind of
deterrent effect i mean figures very we
ourselves counted and you can see the
pictures there are 260 people coming
over the channel yesterday will probably
have been significantly more than that
clearly the prospect of being deported
to rwanda it's not having a deterrent
effect
well i do believe that we will start to
see that as their flights start to take
off
the
government is resolved to making sure
that we do whatever we can to stop
illegal unsafe routes of uh immigration
into this country and that's why we'll
continue to make every effort we can
what are the safe routes well there are
a number of safe routes where people not
only through talent but also through
working with un in different parts of
the country so that's it it's basically
unless unless you can find unless you
can find a un representative to assist
you getting to this country or you
qualify under the point scheme you can't
claim asylum in this country
well the point is that uh when people do
come into the country legally of course
they can claim asylum when they are
again i'm asking how do you get into the
country legally if you're coming here to
seek asylum and you don't have uh
permission to enter you'll be aware
there are a number of countries that
people are already in where they can
apply for asylum i'm not asking about
them i'm asking about you and i'm
telling i'm saying to you about in terms
of the different things that we have
done look we have a track record as a
country of offering places of refuge and
asylum to people from around the world
you know we're already undertaking that
significantly most recently with the
afghan resettlement scheme but also
things like with hong kong and british
nationals overseas there so there's a
number of routes that we have already
taken which are safe legal and we will
continue to stand by that track record
but do whatever we can to deter the
unsafe illegal routes of trying to get
into this country but still and again i
i hate to label this point the majority
of people who come across in small boats
are successful in their asylum claims
here under your scheme anyone who
arrives here illegally could could risk
being sent to to rwanda i don't know how
you square that circle
well because we're trying to stop
illegal unsafe routes and it is the
unsafe routes the routes that are legal
and we are having this perfectly
sensible partnership with rwanda i mean
the commonwealth heads the government
will be meeting there i think next week
uh this is not like it's uh some country
uh that isn't a modern democracy this is
about a partnership which was
established by the home secretary and
it's one that we believe is a good way
to proceed with this unsafe illegal
roots com people being put at risk in
order to get into this country i mean i
have heard one being characterized in
this way at the same time until at least
very relatively recently if it's not the
case this morning the fcdo were warning
against gay britons traveling to rwanda
so i'm not entirely certain that
everyone is sanguine with it but just in
terms of how you proceed from all of
this clearly this government has an
issue with the european convention on
human rights and indeed the european
court on human rights asked about
withdrawing from both the prime minister
said it may very well be necessary to
change law i mean would you would you
really countenance withdrawing ourselves
from the convention that was set up
after the atrocities of the second world
war
well i think that we have never uh put
that as far as i'm aware in our
manifesto in in ill certainly the twenty
years the prime minister seeing it
yesterday but i think it's just uh as we
have done before where we've gone into
court with the echr a number of issues
and judgments have been made in favor of
the government you know we are a law
abiding government and i'm very uh i'm
absolutely sure that frankly we will get
to any future discussions about that but
right now i'm not aware of any decisions
or hints even about that the most
important thing is that we tackle this
issue right now we'll go back i'm sure
to the echr to challenge this initial
ruling and uh because as i say british
judges have made the decision um said
that these flights could go ahead and i
still think that's the best thing that
can happen so i i could i could get this
government complaining about european
convention about the european convention
and indeed echr oversight of our legal
system if this was just a legacy
document that we signed up to in 1950
but the fact of the matter is back when
you were drafting the political
declaration that that sorted out our
relationship between the uk and the
european union you put the convention on
human rights at the very heart of it and
here is the political declaration here
on page two of it the future
relationship between uk and eu should
incorporate the uk's continuing
commitment to respect the framework of
the european convention on human rights
it goes far further than that later on
in the document so i'm not really sure
the point you're making um
the 2019 manufacturer
the idea that you're maintaining that it
is an unforeseen consequence of giving
the european court oversight of our
legal system that the european court
exercises its oversight of our legal
system you signed up to it three years
ago in fact you said it should be under
the
rage
the parties the uk and the eu agree with
the scale and scope of future
arrangements should be underpinned by
long-standing commitments exactly to the
fundamental rights of individuals
including continued adherence and giving
effect to the echr but you can't
complain about something you yourself
signed up to no i'm not complaining in
the slightest our own british judges are
bound by ec the convention on human
rights that's why i think we were
surprised the echr
as i say the quickest decision i've ever
experienced as a minister made the
decision uh last night without him
without
it's a different uh approach that's
taken that's why my home office
colleagues and the home secretary will
be taking steps to look into the impact
of that nevertheless it british judges
made that decision made that ruling and
that's why we will be preparing for the
next flight uh but i think the whole
echr is just a surprise and a
disappointment as i say
if the echr has oversight of our legal
system i just don't get it no it it's a
different situation it's a specific
thing about human rights it's a surprise
at the decision that they reached and
that's why our lawyers in the home
office will be continuing to work on
that and it's why our home office will
be continuing to prepare for the next
flight what level of confidence do you
have then that the next flight will
unlike yesterday take off i'm highly
confident uh you know this decision was
made at a rapid pace
yesterday and as a consequence you know
it's right that the government continues
to try and make sure that we deter
unsafe illegal routes of asylum sorry
people trying to enter the country
because the only people that benefit are
unscrupulous people traffickers often
trying to put people into modern slavery
as well so there's a number of different
things there uh but of course at the
same time uh we also want to make sure
that we continue to focus on the rest of
the government as we are trying to do
today uh as we're introducing
legislation into parliament to help us
be able to process and make those
payments uh to help nearly eight million
households with the cost of living let's
talk indeed about the cost of living
it's it that is on your brief today and
we now have a timetable for for the
payment of the the 650 pounds just give
us a bit of detail on that when can
people expect to get that much needed
assistance so in terms of people who
will have already had 150 pounds or the
majority i think it's about 80 percent
of households will have already had 150
pounds of council tax rebate uh what
they'll be seeing through the payments
is next month uh they'll be getting half
of the 650 pound payment those people on
uh benefits uh indeed although people on
tax credits have to wait a little bit
longer because we don't want to
duplicate payments and then we'll be
making more payments later in the year
so that's people not only the second
half of the 650 pounds but also
pensioners will get an extra 300 pounds
alongside their winter fuel payment and
people with disabilities will get 150
pound payment as well can we can we talk
then just just briefly about about
benefits and i know that you're up in
front of the working pensions committee
next week but when you're in front of
the liaison committee you were asked
whether or not this government would
look at you know some kind of general
uplift in terms of benefits in terms of
of legacy payments i mean you said you'd
go away and have a look at it and see if
it could be done in a cost neutral way
is this something the government is
looking at but some form of increase to
the benefit system before i think it's
april next year when when when the next
kind of a when it would next be looked
at
so i'm looking and
i haven't appeared in front of the
liaison committee so maybe one of maybe
somebody else has um i mean we have look
carefully this is the way through the
legislation we're doing today to give us
the powers to make these payments uh
we're doing it at pace so people will
get money uh next month at the same time
about 70 percent of working families
will benefit from the uplift in the
national insurance threshold
which on average i think will save
families an extra 350 pounds so i think
it's not a case of looking at rates of
individual benefits but by using these
interventions for the one-off payments
is something that we are mobilizing as
quickly as we can totally and and i get
that there are a lot of other ways in
which this government is trying to help
but why is it we obviously we understand
that since we lost that 20 pounds uplift
to universal credit you know in in real
terms you know benefits are the lowest
for some estimate for 30 years
why is this government so reticent to
look at just a general across the board
rise to that one universal payment that
was meant to simplify the benefit system
well we did um do an uplift because i do
i do an upgrading every year well it
rose and we use the
inflation rate uh that was the index
we've always used but of course my
department is really focused as well on
those people who can work to get them
into work and we have seen a record
number of people uh getting into work in
the last few months or sorry very high
hundreds of thousands of people and at
the same time we have um 1.3 million
vacancies and we are trying to do what
we can to help
uh people get into work because that is
definitely the best way of course to
boost somebody's income we will see you
at the working pensions committee next
week and we hope to see in the studio
soon thanks very much